hey leute was genau jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut heute
mal wieder mit einem block und einem
ganz speziellen thema ein kleines
experiment auf das ich mich eigentlich
schon länger einlassen wollte ich habe
das viele freunde von mir auch mein
versprochen dass ich das auch mal
probieren werde einfach weil ich auch
viele muslimische freunde habt die zum
teil zurzeit anfassen sind manche machen
manche halt auch nicht ja diese
fastenzeit die geht ja glaube ich so
ungefähr neun monaten hätte ich das
natürlich nicht mal und ich habe mich
jetzt einfach mal auf einen tag
eingelassen
ich wollte das eigentlich schon vor
einer woche machen aber bin irgendwie
nicht zu bekommen
ich bin gerade aufgestanden habe schon
geduscht und so weiter und wollte mich
erst mal so ein bisschen informieren
damit ich auch alles richtig mache so
damit ich jetzt nichts falsch machen
habe ich gerade einen guten freund von
mir gefragt ob er mir mal so ein paar
informationen geben kann und er hat mich
eine sprachnachricht gesagt ich würde
sagen jetzt hören uns einfach mal kurz
zusammen an
mit einigen aber ich habe doch
unterricht also ich hoffe dieses
klimaanlage stimmt nicht widersprach
[Musik]
heute richtigen was man gemacht
also was gibt's den fünf säulen des
islams und während der fastenzeit
verzichten muslime von sonnenaufgang bis
sonnenuntergang auf essen und trinken
und das hast du es bei uns seit in
erster linie eine form des
gottesdienstes sprich wie fast neben
gottes willen
sozusagen auf die spätere aufnahme war
gar nicht mal so und es gibt halt auch
andere die dslr oder gesehen oder andere
also ich hab so gelernt zum beispiel
dass wir das machen bzw
andere leute ist auch machen ich faste
momentan nicht aber andere wochen zeit
auch um einfach nachvollziehen zu können
das ist halt auch eine geste
beziehungsweise eine art und mit
also er hat mir jetzt nicht behandelt
von wann bis wann das geht aber dass
hinüber also hier steht schon der
ramadan 2018 hat am 16 mai 2018 begonnen
gläubiger muslime in aller welt fasten
dann vier wochen ein essen oder trinken
sind umfasst monat tagsüber tabu ich
habe eigentlich gedacht dass ich was
trinken darf aber irgendwie logisch dass
man es nicht darf also also wenn ich
jetzt den ganzen tag über wasser trinken
würde dann wäre es glaube ich echt easy
machbar so das ding ist frage ist
welchen temperaturen mit einem fall mir
ich kann ja mein körper wird mir
bestimmt schnell ein bisschen
schwindelig oder so auch rauchen und sex
und scheiße muss man jetzt erst nach
sonnenuntergang wie das tägliche fasten
gebrochen und gegessen und getrunken
also das ding ist wenn heute wenn heute
um 21 uhr 34 in köln die sonne untergeht
darf ich nicht richtig voll hören mit
allen möglichen da freue ich mich an
gedauert und ich würde sagen ich nehme
euch heute den ganzen tag lang mit ich
esse wirklich nichts ich kann euch auch
gerne mal kurz in einen kühlschrank
zeigen wir haben hier auch gerade nichts
weil ich morgen in urlaub fliegen und
ich habe eigentlich alles aufgegessen
so also das einzige was man noch
einigermaßen was man anfangen kann sind
hier auch sprüchen und schokolade und
mozzarella sticks du wirklich brot habe
ich gar nicht mehr also wenn ich heute
wirklich was vernünftiges essen wollen
würde müsste ich erst mal einkaufen
worüber ich mir aber eigentlich ziemlich
viele gedanken mache ich glaube da
vielleicht ich jetzt vielleicht mal in
meinen social medias was ich mir dann
heute abend alles holen soll wenn ich es
geschafft habt natürlich bin ich erstmal
wieder gespannt was mein körper macht
weil ich habe noch nie mein ganzes leben
irgendwie mal einen ganzen tag lang
nichts gegessen warum aber ich weiß
natürlich wie es sich anfühlt hunger zu
haben aber ich muss jetzt noch ein
anderes video drehen nebenbei und
und ich würde sagen ich melde mich immer
zwischendurch ich weiß ja nicht ob ich
nur noch raus oder so keine ahnung ein
bisschen sorgen dass im sport machen auf
jeden fall spielt hannah und hier im
hintergrund habe ich meine letzten drei
flaschen wasser die sind alle noch
folgen ich zeige euch die natürlich
heute haben auch noch mal einfach als
beleg dass ich davon nichts angerührt
habe das wasser aus einem kran trinke
ich eigentlich eh nicht einfach weil es
ziemlich kalt ist und überhaupt nicht
schmeckt und ich denke auch mal ein
bisschen ungesundes aber gut deswegen so
viel dazu und hier ist noch ein platz
die ist so voll also das später ich
melde mich sobald ich bin gerade aus dem
keller und hab hier so'n auf video
gedreht was gestern online pommes für
erst morgen kommt mit zum beispiel den
grünen schon deswegen schaut auf jeden
fall vorbei und ich muss schon sagen wir
haben wahrscheinlich erst mal nicht
dabei aber ich kriege immer
kopfschmerzen wendigkeit nichts ist also
so anderen kopfschmerzen und das sind
doch mal zwei stunden oder so keine
ahnung bisher nicht gesprochen und es
ist schon alt also ich würde jetzt halt
normalerweise schon was gegessen haben
wir schon viel besser auch mal am
experimentieren so leute ganz schön
stressig wollte ich habe gerade auf das
video schnell fertig geschnitten
wirklich mit 0 konzentration das ist
halt sehr klar als die konzentration
drunter leidet muss jetzt ein bisschen
autofahren und ja wir haben jetzt gerade
keine ahnung 17 uhr oder so aber ein
bisschen joggen
hier sollte also ab geht auf jeden fall
was ich gerade
euch mal das wetter an hier regnet und
da hinten ist es übertrieben hält
ich habe euch gerade auf instagram
gefragt was ich dann heute abend essen
kann und
was man schreibt ja
das recht zu wünschen wir durch anders
ist wirklich heftig
ich muss mich jetzt auf jeden fall aufs
fahren konzentrieren und
nein mich wenn ich zu hause bin so
leicht kann man ganz klar sehen dass das
ist die sonne schon viele sitz im spiel
kann man es wunderbar sehen war dass die
sonne
mindestens noch eine stunde oben ist ich
bin jetzt die letzten abend abends
marathon gegangen als ich weitere stunde
halt
unterwegs im auto network und wir haben
eigentlich immer gerne joggen natürlich
unter der voraussetzung dass man vorher
hoch
mehr zu sich genommen hat was ich heute
definitiv nicht gemacht habe ich habe
wirklich absolut gar kein wasser
getrunken
wobei ich auch sagen kann obwohl es
ziemlich rahmen ist ist es eher
schlimmer
deren bauch zu haben
als dass ich halt antrinken denkt
derweil das habe ich gar nicht so oft
eigentlich natürlich würde ich jetzt
schon sehr gerne was trinkt aber ich
meine dass auch noch durch für
zweieinhalb stunden
und wir in der 2 joggen und mache mich
einfach mal komplett
jetzt sage ich mal viele fußballspieler
fastenau und die schaffen es ja auch
irgendwie und ja ich bin gespannt was
mein körper dazu sagt so leute ich habe
jetzt noch pizza bestellt und jetzt geht
es noch ganz schnell joggen die sonne
jeden augenblick unter ich würde sagen
ich mach das mal folgendermaßen ich habe
mittlerweile auch ultra durst deswegen
alter ist schon dunkel
die stelle ich war sofort hin es ist
immer ein bisschen provisorisch mit dem
schwimmen laufen aber wer zwischen jetzt
erstmals entgeht so leute so leute wie
mich gestern nicht bald die sonne ist da
nicht ganz untergegangen
wir haben jetzt 20 nach neuen laufe
jetzt noch mal eine vier kilometer fünf
kilometer mache ich öfter abends knapp
20 touristin meine main heißt es total
trocken und theorie für die kamera
qualität gerade ist natürlich mit handy
gefilmt ich muss mich gerade mal ein
bisschen zwischen denen ich habe mir
zeit vom fußball so an gewöhnt dass ich
mich meistens erst mal denen muss und
das mache ich gerade und ich muss sagen
mir ist irgendwie ein bisschen schlecht
ich habe überhaupt gar keinen hunger
mehr wo übelste und es ist noch fucking
waren gerade das ist so heftig das habe
ich auch unterschätzt ich dachte werden
jetzt will ich nur 20 grad es sind noch
26 grad in köln ich muss doch geld holen
damit sie besser gleich bezahlen kann
und ich hab mal eben ein bisschen und
ich wollte auch noch schnell einkaufen
mal ihr habt über instagram eine menge
geschick laufe einfach mal nur gesehen
dass ich absolut fertig bin mit der welt
also das wasser ist wirklich hätte ich
jetzt wasser wird es mir glaube ich
einigermaßen gut gehen aber mir ist
total schlecht respekt das gleich
so leute 20 14 und die sonne geht unter
und ist jetzt ungefähr seit 15 minuten
weg
was jetzt tu ich könnte diese flasche
auf einmal trinken einfach vertrauen
also sport umfassten das weiß nicht wie
das ich kann es nicht also ich kann es
nicht nicht müsste was etwa wenn ich
bald fußball weltmeisterschaft spielen
müsste aber muss ich ja leider nicht es
ist so schwer es ist so schwer wenn man
nichts gegessen hat wörter zu finden
oder passend zu kombinieren dass das
halt immer ich fühle mich als wäre ich
hätte ich alkohol getrunken oder so als
wäre ich ein bisschen betrunken also ich
denke mal kurz die installation holt in
der kalte krieg ist erfrischend nein ich
bin kein moslem nur so als tipp mit der
kohle sehr viele haben geschrieben ich
sage mir döner rollen wobei ich das
erstmals in köln gibt es keinen geraden
und zweitens ist das finde ich
deckt das zwar eine mahlzeit aber nicht
so alles mögliche wisst ihr so als ich
möchte eigentlich mehr essen
ich habe zwar gerade überhaupt noch
keinen hunger im rat wie geschrieben er
fastet selber und am besten wären
datteln wassermelone highschool und
alternative also den mag ich nicht aber
wassermelone hole ich mir auf jeden fall
gleich weiß auch ich habe die pizza für
film nachdem bestellt ich würde sagen
ich gehe noch kurz duschen und dann
fange ich an zu essen so leute was geht
ich habe gerade noch schnell geduscht
und sie deswegen jetzt etwas fertig
außerdem meist schnell einkaufen die
pizza ist angekommen
wir haben hier gekauft die haben wir
einmal eine melone keine wasser meldung
mann sein haus verkaufen das war schon
relativ spät so nass wird der hat mich
total angelacht noch ein joghurt dann
haben wir hier reis mit hackfleisch und
dazu ich könnte mir heute ich trinke
wirklich sehr sehr wenig kohle aber ich
habe mir gedacht kommen die pepsi kannst
du auf jeden fall noch dringend ich habe
euch die ihr heute morgen gezeigt einmal
angerührt und dazu noch erdbeeren mit
kalorien anzahl kann ich mich auf jeden
fall nicht so gut aus nur wenn ich das
jetzt wirklich alles schaffen sollte
habe ich auf jeden fall meine
tagesration ich brauche am tag glaube
ich zwei 1600 kalorien also vielleicht
auch ein bisschen länger keinen plan
erreicht und ich will dass ein neuanfang
mit diesem ding hier
[Musik]
man muss einfach sagen das essen
schmeckt so heftig intensiver als wenn
man muss halt zu jeder mahlzeit ist das
ist echt krass
ich esse jetzt einmal in ruhe so weit
wie ich kann
dann sagt er noch nicht viele geschafft
habe weil es wäre dumm wenn jemand sich
ganz verzuge also bis gleich ich bin
noch voll dabei ich habe jetzt einfach
doch weiter aufgenommen ich weiß noch
mal sagen wollte es war auf jeden fall
eine erfahrung wert
man kann ungefähr sagen es ist so schwer
wie man sich das vorstellt allerdings
ist machbar
das einzige woran ich sehr gelitten habe
es das halt mein konzept ist immer noch
so anscheinend dass meine konzentration
halt extrem gelitten hat normalerweise
ist es so wenn ich halt so wenig erste
bekomme ich kopfschmerzen
das war heute irgendwie nicht so auch
obwohl es so warm draußen also an dieser
stelle respekt und alle die uns
tagtäglich machen ich habe sehr viele
nachrichten bekommen von leuten die
gerade ebenfalls fassten die beiden mega
cool dass wir das auch mal mitmacht und
so alte schöne grüße an euch hat mich
sehr gefreut ja das einfach mal an
dieser stelle übrigens dieser paula
joghurt
schmeckt immer noch gut nicht nur früher
als kind habe ich den gerne gegessen
auch jetzt bisher jedoch aber ich bin
schon recht gut sagt so leute akku ist
leider leer gegangen
ich habe die hälfte von der belohnung
gästen die war echt richtig lecker also
hatten wir eigentlich noch besser
geschmeckt als eine wassermelone zwei
donuts diesen joghurt diesen joghurt
nicht weil ich wirklich jetzt voll mit
ein paar erdbeeren die hitze habe ist
auch dass da und den ganzen reis durst
hatte ich irgendwie fast gar nicht mehr
also mir war nach dem laufen echt
schlecht da habe ich richtig viel
getrunken und ja dann hatte ich
irgendwann plötzlich hunger und ja dann
kann man bei der hunger wieder das ist
ja manchmal normal nach dem sport dass
man erstens zu hunger hat er was soll
ich sagen es war ein sehr aufregender
tag
ein anstrengender tag und es war einmal
eine erfahrung wert also es fühlt sich
einfach durchgehen so an wie wenn man
hunger hat und erst in zwei stunden was
zu essen bekommt und dieses gefühl hat
man halt die ganze zeit und das wird es
nicht zwingend schlimmer
es bleibt eigentlich ungefähr gleich der
bauch tut ein bisschen weh und jemand
kann man halt schön alles essen worauf
man lust hat ich habe allerdings also
ich hätte eigentlich gedacht ich schaffe
noch mehr
ich werde es aber erst mal sagt und
gucken ob ich denke das ist das was wir
im video last auf jeden fall ein
festnahme nach oben dabei ist gefallen
hat wir sehen uns morgen wieder für mich
geht es morgen in urlaub ich hab noch
ein video gedreht was morgen online
kommt ex managerin sogar ein